[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen bei den damen und
herren zu 485 köpfe fünf meinungen schön
dass sie eingeschaltet haben meine
interessanten und kompetenten gäste
heute abend die ehemalige
justizministerin brigitte zypries den
ziemlich spaltung der gesellschaft große
sorgen der hashtag ich bin armut
betroffen trend aktuell auf twitter und
sie fordert dass die politik für eine
bessere um verteilung sorgen so schön
dass sie da sind übrig autorin und
journalistin birgit kelle möchte heute
abend darüber sprechen das trans politik
keine frauenpolitik ist und die jetzt
schon explodierende zahl von trans
kindern weiter steigen wird oli privat
ist vorstandsmitglied und sprecher des
berliner christopher street day heute am
internationalen tag gegen homophobie
möchte er über die diskriminierung von
homosexuellen sprechen last but not
least den werden sie kennen unser stamm
dass bilder an da er ist deutschlands
bester kommunikationsberater und
ehemaliger regierungssprecher ihn treibt
die mehrwertsteuer um und mein name ist
nina schenk und ich freue mich sehr dass
ich heute abend ihren gastgeberin sein
darf mein thema ist heute abend eher
eine frage ich frage mich dass ja schon
länger aber heute auch mal wieder wollen
die grünen eigentlich die lebensfreude
verbieten nicht darauf komme der
gesundheitspolitiker jana stammen hält
die ausrichtung des oktoberfestes in
münchen für unvernünftig es bestehe die
gefahr dass kronor mit neuer härte
zurück kommen zudem warnt er vor harten
neuen virus varianten geht's noch warum
vermiest uns ja noch starben die
sommerlaune und prophezeit dinge die ihr
gar nicht hervor sehen kann von den
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen die eine
dritte absage des oktoberfestes oft
folge hätte ganz zu schweigen kommen wir
nun zu der wichtigsten frage wann sind
wir bloß in die endlosschleife panik
getrieben ja politiker geraten und diese
frage möchte ich gerne in direkt an frau
zypries geben vielleicht sieht sie auch
anders ich sehe es definitiv anders
erstens mal kenne ich diesen
gesundheitspolitiker überhaupt nicht
scheint mir jetzt nicht so die erste
reihe zu sein und ich finde da gehört
man als politische sprecher schlechthin
oder wie als bundestag er ist der
gesundheitspolitische sprecher der
grünen ja ok aber
ich meine man kann jetzt irgendwie nicht
auf jede meinung eingehen und man kann
nicht jedes problem irgendwie dann auch
gleich kontrovers oder oder sich
anziehen sag ich mal ich glaube man muss
auch irgendwann mal sagen okay kann da
ja so sehen warten wir erstmal business
variante kommt mag die regierung das
vorbereiten das halte ich für richtig
dass es wenn es so sein kann dann ist es
richtig man bereitet sich darauf vor
aber das war es dann auch aber finden
sie diese panikmache richtig allein die
finde ich nicht richtig finde also jetzt
mal nicht über den politiker speziell
aber es ist ja schon synonym dafür das
machen ja auch andere politiker leider
sie jetzt schon wieder von neuen virus
varianten gewarnt für die jetzt schon
wieder aufs oktoberfest geblickt wird
muss man den menschen nicht mehr eine
krone atempausen geben naja die krone
atempause kann man nur geben wenn man
kein krone hat deswegen ist es sinnvoll
man beobachtet die fallzahlen und man
reagiert dann aber es macht keinen sinn
zu sagen wer weiß was wir in drei
monaten für fallzahlen haben und
deswegen machen wir jetzt schon mal
dieses oder jenes man hat fast ein
bisschen so das gefühl finde ich
irgendwie alles wollen manche gar keine
corona pause haben sondern irgendwie
diese durchgehendes panik level bis zum
herz durchmarschieren lassen weil genau
genommen weiß keiner von uns was im
herbst kommen wird und ich warte ehrlich
gesagt eher gespannt endlich auf die
evaluierung der korona maßnahmen und auf
ihre wirksamkeit ich glaube dass unsere
regierung mehr damit zu tun haben müsste
eigentlich uns endlich zu erklären
welche maßnahmen eigentlich sinnvoll
waren und welche nicht vor allen dingen
im hinblick auf den herbst weil dort
drohen ja wieder neue maßnahmen oder das
maßnahmen zurückkehren und bevor die
wieder neu erlassen werden also
angefangen irgendwie von kontakt
beschränkungen schulschließung und so
weiter hätte ich gerne jetzt eigentlich
mal eine evaluierung welche dieser
maßnahmen überhaupt jemals sinnvoll
waren denn nur sinnvolle maßnahmen
können wir im herbst auch wieder
wiederholen
januar starben ist ja jemand der nicht
so bekannt ist der stimmt bei der
relativ neu ist im bundestag ist aber so
ein plötzlicher mann vom fach ist
ausgebildeter rettungshund glauben also
luft rettungszentrum geleitet also weiß
aus der praxis zumindest als arzt bevor
er als gesundheitspolitischer sprecher
spricht
auch allerdings bin ich auch da andere
meinungen weil ich meine wir müssen auch
an die wirtschaftlichen folgen denken
was jetzt hier passiert ich meine jetzt
wird wieder die wie die die quasi die
sorge geweckt was ist denn jetzt mit dem
oktoberfest da sind hunderte von leuten
involviert wirtschaftlich involviert die
zwei mal große auswahl haben in münchen
die vertrauen jetzt den ansagen ihre
bürgermeisters ihres ministerpräsidenten
die gesagt haben okay das oktoberfest
findet statt und jetzt kommt wieder die
die die die große angst glocke von der
absage des oktoberfestes da bin ich
dafür dass man ein bisschen pragmatisch
ist auch okay wir überlegen wenn die
situation sich zuspitzt dann nur mit
test- oder wie auch immer aber von
vornherein die verbote ried ist jetzt
auszurufen zum dritten mal in folge das
zeug nicht viel von auch
wirtschaftlichem sachverstand in dieser
sache aber ich kann ihnen sagen ich bin
ja selber eventmanagern hat zwei jahre
extrem oder dieser pandemie gelitten
weil ich so viel verloren habe dass man
sich gar nicht vorstellen kann und als
wir letztes jahr wieder mit dem csd auf
die straße gehen wollt nun den
charakterköpfen quarantäne in hygiene
konzept vorgelegt haben nämlich masken
zu tragen was uns dann ja auch
genehmigt wurde und wir das gemacht
haben wieder rauszieht haben ausgetragen
dann wurden wir auch hier aus eurem haus
kritisiert dafür dass es einige gab die
keine getragen haben weil gleichzeitig
dass beim nena konzert irgendwann
erinnert sich ja noch so leicht daran
irgendwie die leute in einzelne ecken
100 heißt es noch ganz genau und wir
von vielen medien also ich will das
jetzt auch gar nicht nur auf die medien
schieben sondern wir ja eher sagen dass
verlangen dass sie sich jetzt ja aktuell
ich weiß über über den winter viel in
den staaten weil ich einfach die crawler
maßnahmen teilweise eben auch ein
bisschen davon entfliehen wollte und
nicht die ganze zeit maske tragen wollte
und dort hat man ja schon sehr in
freiheit dann gelebt aber wenn ich jetzt
hier bin wie viele menschen ist immer
noch freiwillig tragen weil sie immer
noch angst haben da muss man doch sagen
das ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt die
mehrheit die das so toll findet das
alles einfach gelockert wird und
aufgehoben wird also man sollte schon
danach gucken wer wer will da ist also
einfach pauschal zu sagen die mehrheit
ist dagegen ist jetzt auch irgendwie
nicht aber das ist nicht das thema
ehrlicherweise ich meine jeder sollte
sich so schützen wie er es oder sie es
für richtig halten
aber da muss man ein fest verbieten was
überwiegend im freien stattfindet
absolut das haben wir bei der demo
erlebt und mussten die maske tragen
natürlich obwohl alle wissenschaftler ja
schon im sommer 2000 letzten 21 aber man
musste ja schon im nach dem ersten
locker und das draußen der ansteckung
sehr gering ist ja jetzt langsam
wirklich absurd mit allem respekt vor
dem csd ob wir wissen das ist ja nicht
nur eine feier zu um die rechte von
homosexuellen transgender und anderen
minderheiten zu stärken sondern ist
mittlerweile ja auch ein großes
volksfest wo viele menschen kommen und
dann diese politische botschaft parat
das ist eine demonstration seien wir
ehrlich es ist eine demonstration sie
sagen ist sind die demonstration sonst
der demonstration angemeldet das ist
sicherlich auch der herr angewiesen mit
seiner rein volksfest und es ist aber
mit sehr viel spaß und mit sehr viel
freude und diese bilder werden doch auch
vermittelt also zeigen sie mir einen csd
wohl nicht getanzt gelacht wird
geschunkelt wird und auf den wagen die
große party abgeht mit politischer
botschaft das bestreitet ja kein mensch
aber mit dem kerner du dich dabei freude
und spaß zu haben ich wollte aber auch
was anderes hinaus aber was schreibe ich
als kleiner im kreuz gehabt zu sagen der
csd findet nicht statt aber jetzt zu
sagen das oktoberfest sollen die stadt
finden sich völlig ab so ich bin absolut
dagegen sieht das genauso wir nur sagen
dass ich das gefühl habe das immer noch
so viele deutsche also ich weiss nicht
die prozentzahl aber dass ich dass er
selber merke wie viele immer noch das
verlangen nach gewissen regeln haben und
jetzt das das sollte doch im freiwillig
es sollte doch jeder für sich
entscheiden also wenn ich ins schwimmen
gehe dann gibt es immer noch ich kann
jetzt keine prozentzahl sagen aber gibt
es immer noch einen gewissen anteil von
menschen und die sind 20 25 70 und 80
also ganz unterschiedlich die immer noch
freiwillig maske tragen obwohl sie es
nicht müssen aber sollen wir aber aber
die frage ist müssen wir uns der angst
sozusagen auf kalorien beugen und da und
ich will es nicht unendlich zeit einen
unterschied zu machen dass man sagt
jemand dem ist jemand dem es angst macht
auf einen csd zu gehen oder ins zum
oktoberfest zu gehen weil er glaubt dass
er sich dort an steckt der soll zu hause
bleiben also ich finde inzwischen ist es
einfach so dass die gesellschaft in die
ihre freiheit wieder zurück haben muss
und diejenigen die angst haben die
müssen selber schauen wie sie wie sie
selbst den abstand halten aber wir
können nicht mehr verlangen dass ein
ganzes volk eben seine freiheit aufgibt
nur weil manche menschen in ihrer angst
bleiben möchte diejenigen schützen ja
und mit einer fft zwei maskierte ja und
es geht natürlich auch um die frage
welche varianten sind es und da kommen
wir wieder auf ihren
gesundheitspolitischen sprecher der
grünen der ja offenbar von einer
variante ausgeht die wir heute noch gar
nicht kennen und das ist ja das problem
also bei dem was wir heute haben können
wir sagen wir können das alles so frei
geben jeder soll selber machen weil wenn
man halbwegs ordentlich geimpft ist dann
passiert einem nicht so sonderlich viel
selbst wenn man sich infiziert
aber wenn es natürlich eine variante
gibt die gegen die dass der im serum das
impfserum nicht wirkt und wir dann
irgendwie nah diese variante bekommen
dann haben wir wieder eine ganz andere
diskussion aber ja ich meine das ist
irgendwie so wie asterix immer gesagt
hat kann sein dass uns selber laufen
kopf fällt
ist doch ein thema das die die gedanken
über selbstmord bei kindern und
jugendlichen sich verdreifacht haben
während der krone pandemie das irgendwie
menschen eben veranstalter kultur alle
gelitten und wenn ich hier durch berlin
gehe dann habe ich das gefühl alle tun
wieder so als wären niemals gewesen ich
finde da sollte man jetzt eher darüber
über die spätfolgen auch von maßnahmen
aber von allen von der gesamten corona
bande minuten berliner pandemien die
spätfolgen sind ja sehr emotionalisieren
sondern das zweite thema was auf twitter
auch sehr stark immer zur endet ist
jetzt ändern und wie zwischen den
geschlechtern ist und da habe ich heute
eine frau ihr zu gast die eine sehr
andere meinung als der mainstream halten
glaubt kann man sagen ja ich würde gerne
zu einer etwas differenzierten
diskussion im team gender komplex kommen
weil wir inzwischen in meinen augen
einen overkill haben und dinge
zusammenwerfen die nicht mehr dieselben
interessen verbinden das heißt
frauenpolitik ist heute immer nur noch
gender politik und ich würde gerne
diesen gender top auseinander nehmen und
sagen frauenpolitik ist für mich zum
beispiel keine transporte trans frauen
und biologische frauen sind
unterschiedliche komponenten und wir
erleben inzwischen gerade auch durch die
internationale erfahrung die wir
inzwischen wie männer jetzt die
weiblichkeit definieren und sich in
ehemalige frauendomäne hineinbegeben dh
sie kapern jetzt frauen quotenplätze sie
kapern jetzt den internationalen
frauensport weil sie jetzt gegen frauen
antreten mit der behauptung sie sei 1
frauen wir erleben in england dass sie
selbst in den frauen gefängnissen zugang
bekommen weil dort auch das gesetz sagt
selbstdefinition von frau also jeder der
frau sein will darf frau sein und wir
erleben im zuge dieses ganzen transalls
dass inzwischen die zahlen von trans
angeblichen trans kindern explodieren
teil weil in manchen altersgruppen um
den faktor 1000 500 und das ist einfach
besorgnis erregen und da finde ich es
sehr schwierig dass unsere
bundesregierung gerade ein gesetz plant
das jedem bundesbürger das recht geben
soll einfach auf dem amt durch eine
einfache aussage sein geschlecht zu
wechseln und das für kinder ab 14 wissen
sie was passiert wenn leute wie sie
sagen transalp dann passiert das was wir
in florida gerade erleben nämlich dass
der gouverneur eingesetzt lässt was der
cd heißt und wo lehrer mit ihren
schülern nicht mehr aufklärung über
homosexualität überhaupt sprechen dürfen
da darf das wort gay nämlich gar nicht
mehr den mund genommen werden und wenn
man einfach über transalp spricht dann
scheint es offensichtlich so zu sein
dass sie halt einfach noch nie so eine
person kennengelernt habe und was die
fünf schweren weg teilweise durch machen
welche diskriminierung aldi erleben und
ich verstehe ja auch teilweise andere
seiten ich habe das selbst letztes jahr
bei an einem beispiel erlebt in einem
handelsunternehmen hier in berlin
lagerlogistik trans frau die eben noch
in der transaktion ist und jetzt aber
von der von der diversity gruppe des
unternehmens unterstützt wird nämlich
auf dem weg dass sie natürlich auch
nicht damit einverstanden ist jetzt ein
eigenen raum zu bekommen sondern sie
will natürlich auch teil der weiblichen
bzw der gesamten belegschaft seien und
dass man jetzt beim thema umkleiden
natürlich frauen hat die dann vielleicht
irgendwie diese bedenken haben die sie
gerade anbringen aber da muss man sich
doch zusammensetzen eine gemeinsame
lösung finden ist sehr schnell setzt
genau aber dann kann man durch die trans
menschen nicht einfach abschieben in
einzelnen rollen kommen und sagen der
transalp alle kinder lassen sich jetzt
plötzlich umoperieren also das ist
einfach
zurückkehren einfach es geht es geht ja
auch um die konkrete umsetzung ich habe
übrigens mit sehr vielen trans frauen
vor allen dingen auch gesprochen und ich
kann ihnen sagen ja es gibt diese
menschen die das auch sehr ernst und die
dänen denen das ein echtes anliegen war
und die diese tradition hinter sich
gebracht haben und die deswegen auch
genau wissen was das bedeutet
gleichzeit ich sehen wir tatsächlich
dass es einen hype gibt und das
definieren nichtig so sondern ehrlich
gesagt die fachleute die ärzte wir haben
international ärzteverbände in
australien in schweden in england auch
in deutschland in kanada überall sagt
man es sind explodierende zahlen und wir
haben es hier nicht mit wirklichen trans
kindern zu tun in der mehrheit sondern
wir haben es mit mit kindern zu tun vor
allen dingen mit mädchen die sich in
ihrem körper unwohl fühlen und die
plötzlich durch diese idee nach dem
motto ich kann ja verhindern dass mein
körper weiblich wird anfangen zu glauben
sie seien trans und das ist ein größeres
problem und wir lösen das problem nicht
indem wir so tun als seien diese kinder
jetzt einfach trans und indem wir sie
auf diesen weg schicken denn was hier
passiert und auch das berichten ja
betroffene auch in deutschland
inzwischen wir haben inzwischen eine
generation von trans menschen die diese
tradition gemacht haben und wieder
zurückkehren weil sie gemerkt haben das
war der falsche weg und ich bin auch
mutter von vier kindern und ich kann
ihnen sagen ich möchte jedes kind davor
bewahren eine entscheidung zu treffen
die ja nicht dienen ja nicht einfach nur
ein outing ist sondern die mit
körperlicher veränderungen zu tun hat
pubertäts blogger zu nehmen bedeutet
dass sie ihre natürliche entwicklung
dass sie die bremsen wenn sie ihren
körper operieren lassen sie werden
lebenslang patient wenn sie transnet
trotzdem
überlegt was ich sagen so gerät das ist
das einfach dass es das eigentlich nicht
gibt und das habe ich jetzt ganz
verbreiten ja aber es war einfach
früheren wichtig war und jetzt wird es
halt einfach sichtbare man gibt diesen
menschen eine plattform eine eine bühne
und bzw man lässt sie endlich auch sein
wie sie sind oder eben zu sich selbst
finden unterstützt ziehen aber da bin
ich und die brauchen ja wenn ich dabei
aber dann eine frage denn ich würde
ihnen geht konkret gerne eine frage
finden sie es fair dass zum beispiel im
internationalen frauensport inzwischen
selbst erklärte frauen gegen echte bio
frauen dann sagen wir mal vielleicht als
gegensatz antreten dürfen und jetzt
ihnen die medaillenränge wegnehmen das
passiert nämlich real finden sie es
gerecht und fair dass in england trans
frauen die biologische männer sind
anspruch haben im frauengefängnis zur
seite die ersten gerichte urteile sind
da wegen sexuellen übergriffen in kanada
hat sich versucht eine transfer ins
frauenhaus einzuklagen einfach aus
prinzip
diese dinge passieren real und ich
möchte gerne dass weiblichkeit etwas ist
was anerkannt wird und was mir nicht von
männern definiert wird wo kommen wir
denn hin was ist das das schöne frauen
weg aber die die nicht mehr wahr die
heimlichkeit überhaupt noch an
natürlichen faktoren denn heutzutage
eine eine trans personen zur transfusion
übergehen will muss sie halt immer noch
wahnsinnig diskriminierende fragebögen
ertragen und und eine es wird nach wie
vor eben eine aufklärung das fordern wir
übrigens in unserem heute
veröffentlichten forderungskatalog des
berliner csd auch das eben eine
komplette kostenübernahme bei
beratungsangeboten stattfinden und so
weiter ich glaube die politik ist
einfach nicht schnell genug hinterher
gekommen diese menschen ausreichend zu
unterstützen und da begleiten die
menschen an die hand zu nehmen also es
geht ja um
da kommen bei frau kelle verstehe ich
ihren glauben verstiegen in kernpunkt
mein eindruck ist da kommen verschiedene
sachen zu sein also eine sportlerin die
als man
im
sicherheits man als frau führt gern als
frau leben möchte die vielleicht keine
ahnung die siebte achte neunzehnte der
mannschaft ist die ersten vier werden
genommen die nach ihrer
umwandlung ihrem transgender prozess
erfolgt eine transfusion ihrer
transmission bei den frauen antritt und
dann goldmedaille gegen alle gewinnen
würde das wäre natürlich im sport nicht
fair die beispiele kennt ihr das ist
nicht fair weil das ist ein vorteil in
biologischer vorteil da kann keine frau
natürliche frau geborene frau wie man
das richtig nennt daneben mithalten es
ist völlig klar das zweite ist wenn eine
frau die nach der transaktion und ein
mann der transgender ist und daneben
umgewandelt ist als frau sich ein klagt
in ein frauenhaus kann man sagen das ist
wenn es sexuelle übergriffe gibt kann
wahrscheinlich da nicht sein
gibt das und england gibt es die
prozesse ist aber dass alles nach sich
an wahlvolks sehen wenn man da ein
exempel statuieren will aus politischer
sicht dann ebenso aktive aktivistisch
ist und sagt okay ich möchte ein
beispiel eben geben dafür dass es
möglich ist für jemanden nach der
transaktion auch in ein solches
frauenhaus rein zu gehen um die gleichen
rechte zu erwirken wie alle anderen also
mich als vollwertige frau sehen in
diesem sinne dass ein politisches ding
wenn es wenn es jenseits von gewalt ist
oder dergleichen dafür habe ich
verständnis wofür ich kein verständnis
sagt und was leider offenkundig und das
ist ja ihr kernpunkt gewesen
immer häufiger vorkommt wenn wenn eine
ganze industrie mittlerweile aus
wissenschaftlern aus psychologen auch
aus ärzten im
bestimmte tendenzen bei kindern
überinterpretiert
beispiel mädchen klettern auf bäume und
spielten mit pfeil und bogen und fühlt
sich ein bisschen mehr als kennen wir ja
alle nicht tolle frauen ab holte gleich
20 und dann sagt auf einmal ein
psychologe um gottes willen nicht
vielleicht müssen wir da mal vorsichtig
sein vielleicht für die sich mehr als
junge und werden dann durch
entsprechende psychologische
beratung in diese richtung gebracht auch
darüber gibt es ja berichte und das darf
natürlich nicht sein dass ich so was für
selbstständig und da bin ich sehr bei
ihm hier wird es die reine einmal die
einschätzung von frau zypries noch ab
und zu der thematik
also ich sag mal so ich glaube wenn
jemand so eine so ein prozess hinter
sich gebracht hat und dann im anderen
geschlecht tatsächlich lebt mit allen
operationen und hormongaben und allen
dann muss man es akzeptieren und auch
rechtlich akzeptieren dass er dann ein
anderes geschlecht hat da habe ich
überhaupt gast einsetzt als ja auch
schon so genau und ja deswegen bin ich
bei dem frauenhaus beispiel völlig bei
béla anda würde ich auch sagen wenn sie
denn eine frau ist und wenn sie gewalt
ausgesetzt ist als frau warum sollte ich
ins frauenhaus selbstverständlich so
sieht das also da hätte ich gar kein
thema mit die andere frage ist in der
tat ab wann sagt man so ein prozess
findet selbstbestimmt stadt kann man das
schon tatsächlich in der pubertät machen
sie haben vorhin von pubertäts blockern
geschehen gesprochen da muss ich
gestehen ich bin jetzt aber juristin und
keine psychologin da wäre ich allerdings
vorsichtig also ich glaube auch dass die
pubertät so eine phase ist wo man dann
doch öfter mal mit sich selber und
seinem dasein zweifelt also wenigstens
kenne ich das familien noch
und wo man auch wie gedacht also ich
würde schon sagen wenn ich das richtig
weiß es ist ja jetzt so dass man
volljährig sein muss und dass man es
gerne gleich an dass man dann zwei
jahren eine psychotherapie machen muss
erstmal man dann überhaupt hormone
nehmen kann also so kenne ich das
wenigstens bei uns aus dem
kreise das ist das also soll ich auch
dafür dass man das ein bisschen später
hinzu und bei den was die kinder
anbelangt ich kenne auch erstaunlich
viele kinder die irgendwie meinen mit
drei oder mit vier ohne dass sie
irgendwelche vorbilder in der familie
oder sonstwo hätten geht sie gehörten
dem anderen geschlecht an und die jungen
rennen bedrücken rum und sagen ich werde
mal sängerin
also was ist das problem das heißt ja
noch lange aktuell sein natürlich also
ich nein das habe ich auch gemacht mich
gerne verkleiden an der geist kennt und
zum glück hatte ich eltern die mich
unterstützt und das ist halt
anders so schlimmer wenn sie das halt
irgendwie dann so sagen die ärzte dann
dazu drängen usw da werden dann so
einzelfälle ich weiß nicht mehr ob ich
weiß dass mit dem zurück das habe ja
schon gehört aber was sie sagen mit dem
dass die ärzte dann die kinder dazu
drängen weil sie einmal irgendwie ein
kleid anhatte es ist halt einfach
übertrieben und das ganze
industrie die sich mittlerweile haben
wir noch ein beispiel meine ich von
einer zwölfjährigen mit nein es gibt
nein ich habe keinen korken nicht fall
kein konkretes beispiel von einer
zwölfjährigen sondern man kann
eigentlich sagen dass diese beispiele
weltweit genauso stattfinden wobei der
druck tatsächlich nicht von den ärzten
kommen sondern es ist tatsächlich so
dass wir sogar zu wenig therapeuten
gerade im deutschen raum haben aber
internationaler international sehen wer
tatsächlich dass sich eine industrie
entwickelt hat und dass man zum beispiel
eben in ländern wie den usa teilweise
schon kinder unter zehn jahren mit
pubertäts blockern behandelt werden die
idee dahinter ist nach dem motto das ist
ein trans kind wir lassen gar nicht erst
zu dass es sein das geschlecht
entwickelt damit man es besser operieren
kann dazu muss man wissen pubertät ist
ein normalzustand ja das heißt pubertäts
blogger unterbinden die normale
entwicklung eines kindes das ist genau
genommen körperverletzung und deswegen
haben jetzt inzwischen weil man
festgestellt hat tatsächlich auch eltern
lassen sich infizieren davon er deutet
in deutschland berichten professoren das
inzwischen eltern bei ihnen sitzen mit
siebenjährigen kindern und behaupten
ihre kinder seien trans man weiß gar
nicht genau sind die kinder hier
überhaupt die treibenden kräfte oder
finden die eltern ist gerade schick dass
sie irgendwie ein besonderes kind haben
und das meine ich mit verstehen sie ich
möchte überhaupt nicht schlechtreden
film und jene
netflix serien inzwischen sozusagen zur
trans kids es wird schon in gewisser
weise geheilt bis hin zu germany's next
topmodel wo jetzt quasi ständig
aktualisiert und problem das
ist auch und das ist tatsächlich in
meinen augen da was das ist so getan
wird als sei das eine einfache sache man
muss einfach sagen trans menschen müssen
ihr leben lang patienten ein leben lang
patienten das ist nicht schön ja das ist
ein gewaltiger
müssen
sie müssen ihr leben lang
wieder zurück sozusagen und jeder der
einmal den beipackzettel von der pille
gelesen hat darüber diskutieren wir viel
ob das nicht zu viel ist für die frau ja
das sind bonbons im vergleich zu dem was
trans menschen ihr leben lang schlucken
müssen und deswegen müssen wir sehr
vorsichtig sein und bei kindern ist das
tatsächlich sind das sozusagen dinge die
können sie nicht mehr rückgängig machen
wenn sie die pubertät unterbrechen das
können sie nicht wieder einschalten
später sondern diese kinder sind für ihr
leben gezeichnet und deswegen möchte ich
gerne dass wir das diskutieren und
vielleicht einfach nur grundsätzlich ja
wir können ja eigentlich ich verstehe
jede trans frau die sagt ich möchte ich
habe diesen prozess hinter mich gebracht
und ich habe gibt weiß was ich tue und
ich möchte anerkannt werden in ihrer
weiblichkeit das kann ich so auch zu
lassen aber wir sind wir müssen eine
grundsatzentscheidung treffen nämlich
darf man sozusagen ein gesetz machen
oder wollen wir in einer gesellschaft
leben in der die frage ob ich einem mann
oder eine frau bin nur eine frage ist
einer reinen aussage vor einem
standesamt ja die länder die das gemacht
haben die haben diese probleme jetzt wir
haben das noch nicht in deutschland aber
unsere regierung will das machen und
wenn wir dann sei ja das darf man so
werden wir mit der konsequenz leben
müssen dass rein biologische männer ohne
tradition behaupten eine frau zu sein
und wir ihnen diesen ausweis ausstellen
müssen und sie damit uneingeschränkt zu
allen positionen und überall zugang
haben weil man kann ja nicht sagen okay
wir erkennen deine weiblichkeit an aber
nicht im sport aber nicht beiden frauen
quotenplatz aber nicht im frauenhaus das
sondern es gibt ja immer nur ja oder
nahe sind alles themen die definitiv
debattiert werden müssen tja aber auch
dass der zuschauer gerade draußen
wahrscheinlich direkt eigene meinung
dazu hatte er gerne auch kommentieren
oder und schreiben und jetzt kommen wir
zu einem anderen thema nicht zu
transpondern zur diskriminierung und
damit sie ihn absolut die
diskriminierung also gerade heute zum
internationalen der hobbit ist ganz ganz
großes problem dass er die
diskriminierung von menschen eher wieder
zunimmt wir sind gerade dabei die rolle
rückwärts zu machen und erleben gerade
in berlin hat das im vergleich zum
vorjahr ein anstieg wieder und
angezeigte fälle nämlich auf über 520
fälle
gewalt gegen
tiere menschen gegeben und das ist
sicherlich auch ein grund durch internet
mobbing und so weiter aber die ikone
pandemie hat dazu geführt dass
schutzräume für tiere menschen verloren
gegangen sind und dass heutzutage oder
wir immer noch damit leben müssen dass
viele schutzräume weggefallen sind und
nicht mein für mich als privilegierten
schwulen mann ist es sicherlich kein
problem wenn sie jetzt endlich den klub
nicht mehr geht aber eben für eine
transfusion für
lesbische frauen junge quere schule
trans menschen die aussies dass da
schutzräume wegfallen durch die pandemie
weggefallen sind aber sicherlich jetzt
auch wer einfach mal anstieg der
diskriminierung wir erleben dass gerade
in den öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
stattfindet das ist sicherlich ein
großes problem und deswegen engagiere
ich mich auch im berliner csd ev und
weiß dass es wichtig ist weiterhin auf
die straße zu gehen auch wenn mir immer
bewusst ist dass ich als privilegierter
schwuler mann da überhaupt keine
probleme mehr erleben wer ist der nicht
privilegiert
ich würde interessieren gehen können sie
uns irgendetwas sagen über die frage
welchen wer sind die täter also wir
sagen wenn man wenn man also die reine
statistik jetzt irgendwie anstieg von
von straftaten ich habe mich gerade
gefragt sozusagen erstmal wie inwiefern
spielt corona sozusagen der verlust von
schutzräumen wir waren alle in
quarantäne oder beziehungen es hat gar
nicht stattgefunden
also wer sind denn die täter durch
welche täter steigen denn die zahlen an
also wenn ich halt nicht mehr in denen
in den klub gehen kann also in den
nehmen wir mal das schmutz in berlin was
ja dann über zwei jahre auch
größtenteils geschlossen war wo man eben
früher sich einfach besser
ausleben konnte ist das halt heute hat
es halt alles zu hause stattgefunden und
wie ich das von der polizeistatistik
wäre eben auch von der berliner polizei
gehört habe sind auch daneben
diskriminierungen und angriffe zu hause
nachbarschaftsverhältnis extrem
angestiegen oder eben passiert ja weiß
es eben immer noch nicht
selbstverständlich wenn nebenan das
lesbische paar wohnt wir tun immer alle
so also dass er dankbar berlin damit ihr
seid ja ja das aber ist fragen sie mal
bei der polizei
ich bin hier wirklich bin wirklich ich
bin 84 nach berlin gezogen bei meinem
damaligen freund nebenan wohnte ein ein
zwillingspaar das lässt mich war die
hatten zwei große doggen gewohnten
autoren der zwei zimmer wohl und kein
mensch hat sich
1986 darüber aufgeregt ist es war mitten
in berlin in charlottenburg
trotzdem waren waren waren diejenigen
die um es sexuell waren es bestehe
weniger damals glaube ich etwas
meditativ weitaus mehr für ihre recht
wir kämpfen müssen sie werden sagen das
ist heute immer noch so als es heute der
fall ist wo es eine große
gesellschaftliche oder im schatten der
anderen regionen einer engen draht ist
es vielleicht immer noch schlimm in
pirmasens auch wenn man sagt ich bin
schwul und händchenhaltend durch die
straßen geht gleichgeschlechtlich aber
in berlin
mag es so viele übergriffe geben
vielleicht aber auch weil sich mehr
menschen öffentlich dazu bekennen es
können ja auch daran liegen die wir
sollten nicht reden es ist nicht
akzeptabel wenn das so ist nur es hat
sich doch auch viel getan in den letzten
aber sie reden sogar klein mit ihrem
einen guten beispiel das mag auch sein
dass das so ist also ich als thüringer
meine erste diskriminierung tatsächlich
nicht auf dem land in thüringen
erlebt ich bin noch saalfeld sondern als
ich mit 16 nach berlin kam und eine
ausbildung zum einzelhandelskaufmann
gemacht habe in einem warenhaus da saß
ich dann irgendwann bei der
personalchefin im büro hinter mir wurde
zu geschlossen und dann hat sie mich
zusammen mit dem abteilungsleiter sehr
in die mangel genommen
ich hätte doch hiv und so weiter was
überhaupt nicht stimmt ja das mit 16 ich
hatte damals zum glück schon mein freund
der heute mein ehemann ist worüber ich
eben sehr froh bin dass das endlich
möglich ist und auch dazu muss sagen
die er erst 217 wirklich möglich war ist
ja nun auch immer wieder sondern hat ja
nun lange gedauert aber ich wollte
das wasser eine der wenigen
diskriminierung damit bin ich bei dieser
bei dieser privilegierung und um das
zelt zu sagen ich kann mich halt
verteidigen und ja maskulin toxic
nicht angegriffen aber sobald jemand da
schwächer wird oder eben auch nur
annährend feminin ist als man dann wird
er eben des krimi hat nicht einmal eine
sache möchten wir gerne mal reinschauen
das ist ja und zwar das was gerade auch
schon angesprochen wurde von béla anda
mit dem video wo sie auf merkel
getroffen sind jetzt haben sie
eigentlich gerade auch schon selbst mit
der eheschließung fast angesprochen aber
wir hören da einmal ganz kurz rein
wann darf ich meinem freund irgendwann
ehemann nennen wenn ich ihnen hört nicht
ich kenne bei mir in der cdu und
schließe mich gleich mit allen viele die
sich sehr sehr viele gedanken über
dieses thema machen die längste sagen da
wären die gleichen werte gelebt und
trotzdem irgendwo vielleicht
aufgewachsen sind neben gefühl mann und
frau das ist eben die ehe wie wir sie
kennen und das andere ist eine genau so
wertvolle partnerschaft bei frau merkel
antwort für sie diskriminierend als sie
gehört haben nee sie hat ja ein beispiel
oder sie hat ja sehr gut erklärt wie sie
ihre einstellung dazu verändert hat ja
ich meine ich bin dann nach
spießrutenlauf man sich gesagt habe dass
ich dass ich sie mag oder jetzt sogar ja
da gesagt dass ich ein fan von chaplin
also ich mochte sie ja über viele
strecken sehr gern in den dingen die sie
gemacht hat und eben dieses zuzugeben
ich habe da einen wandel durchgemacht
über die zeit ich habe nicht eines
besseren belehren lassen das will ich ja
von den menschen das ist ja das was ich
auch in meiner heimat erreichen will
oder das mit den menschen wenn ich auf
die straße gehe erreichen will dass sich
durch das was ich mache den menschen
eben ihre berührungsängste nehmen und
sie dadurch aufkläre weil ich nur glaube
weil ich nur an bildung glaube dass ist
das einzige womit wir die menschen
weiter bringen aber trotzdem hat sie
mich insofern diskriminiert dass am ende
dagegen gestimmt hat und deswegen nicht
mit der antwort die war vier minuten
lang wie immer von frau merkel und
keiner hat sie verstanden aber dass sie
dann drei tage später im bundestag hat
dagegen gestimmt hat das mag
parteipolitisch nachvollziehbar gewesen
sein aber es hat mich trotzdem
enttäuscht nachdem sie so ausführlich
erklärt warum sie heute eben es
unterstützt aber vielleicht kann man
doch auch als ich mich stört eigentlich
nur der begriff diskriminierung wissen
sie es kann unterschiedliche meinungen
geben zum thema ehe ich zum beispiel
habe ein gründliches verständnis
es gibt ein muslimisches ehe verständnis
dass geht davon aus dass man irgendwie
mehrere frauen haben das lehne ich auch
ab ich kann wertschätzen ich war auf
meiner sendung mit mit zwei bezaubernden
70-jährigen herren zwar ein schwules
paar die seit 50 jahren zusammen waren
und so und die waren wirklich sehr süß
wo ich sagen würde die haben die haben
es geschafft quasi 50 jahre zusammen zu
bleiben was eine großartige leistung ist
und das kann nicht wertschätzen leiden
nicht mehr verdient als zum beispiel
leute die vielleicht zwei jahre zusammen
sind aber nicht gleichgestellt aber ist
etwas was man sich verdient
sie sich anfühlt nur klar ist das ist
mein partner das ist mein eingetragener
lebenspartner sie wissen ja nicht wie
sich das anfühlt das nur sagen zu können
das war die einzige möglichkeit die wir
hatten das ist mein freund können was
ihnen sagen dass man nein konnte ich
eben nicht es war eben nicht mein
ehemann ich konnte es halt nicht sagen
weil ich mir das gesetz weil weil mir
das gesetz ist verboten hat es ist ein
bisschen mehr
sein dass man rechtlich von die sich
also dass mir das jemand sagt ja
irgendwie
justiz hat das ist natürlich dann also
ich konnte es halt nicht ich konnte es
nicht sagen und deswegen hat frau merkel
das gefragt und dass sie dieses
verständnis dann aufgebaut hat und
gesagt okay alles klar wir geben das
jetzt in die offene abstimmung das war
ja auch toll es war auch alles ein
riesen zu fall und es war weit haben für
den herrn eben auch sagen ja aber
trotzdem war es längst überfällig war
andere ländern das heißt ja das ist ja
aber da so zu tun als ob das jetzt
irgendwie alles dann selbstverständlich
ist ich meine wir sehen doch die rolle
rückwärts stefan prantner von der
thüringer schlaf de hat danach antrag
gestellt dass das wieder rückgängig
gemacht wird und nicht er lebe heute
selbst in meiner familie dass diese
partei gewählt wird also wenn plötzlich
meine er wieder hinten an gestellt wird
weil sie nicht so wichtig ist wie
irgendwie andere themen dann muss ich
sagen das betrifft sie denn vielleicht
irgendwie nicht ob man ehemann oder
ehefrau sagen kann aber mir war es halt
wichtig dass ich das sagen kann ich bin
heute 16 jahren mit meinen partnern
zusammen und sehr stolz darauf was man
sagen toll das können viele von sich
nicht sagen aber immer noch um den
ernsthaften punkte zu jemand da haben
sie wirklich land viele und sie mache
ich jetzt als gemeinde als gemeinde von
von als interessenvertreter viel für
gekämpft weltweit für gekämpft und wer
ist eine errungenschaft dieser auch
nicht wieder genommen werden ich finde
das ist auch ein legal ist
ziel von ihnen gewesen und das ist auch
egal in diesem sinne das ist auf jeden
fall jetzt legalisiert worden ist und
das soll man ihnen auch nicht wieder
nehmen und jede tendenz dahin ist falsch
und das soll gewahrt bleiben dass man
nicht schon
und ich kann auch nicht verstehen wenn
sich parteien oder minderheiten dagegen
stellen denn das ist ein begehrter genau
sitz unserer gesellschaft und zwischen
rechten die wir eben auch anderen
gruppen geben müssen wie alles andere
auch jetzt haben wir die ehe und das ist
gut es geht mir heute darum warum ich
auf die straße gehe es wenn mir heute
eine drag-queen sagt dass sie sich vor
zehn jahren wohl gefühlt hat in der u
bahn zur party zu fahren und heute ist
auf gar keinen fall mehr machen würde
sondern maximal mit dem taxi dahin fährt
aufgedrückt dann macht mir das doch
sorgen was ist denn da passiert in den
letzten 20 jahren warum das warum ging
das vor zehn jahren warum geht es heute
nicht mehr ich habe die antwort darauf
nicht ich verdiene an regelschule
freunde aus köln geben die sagen das
täterprofil hat sich einfach verändert
in köln haben sie ja genau das selbe
problem auch die schwulenszene war
völlig ist alles war völlig in ordnung
man es ist eine liberale stadt
trossingen und große schwimm szene in
köln und inzwischen hat man einfach ein
größeres problem seit vielen jahren mit
muslimischen minderheiten das ist das
problem das heißt wir haben quasi eine
neue schwulenfeindlichkeit die
eigentlich gar nicht sozusagen aus
unserer gesellschaft kommt unseren die
tatsächlich weil sie durch einen ganzen
ein anderes geschlechterbild und auch
ein ganz anderes bild auf homosexualität
kommt und das ist ein muslimisches bild
und damit müssen wir uns
auseinandersetzen das macht überhaupt
keinen sinn dass totzuschweigen weil
deswegen fragte ich nach den
tätergruppen wir müssen wir müssen dann
wieder dorthin zurück dass man eben dass
auch sie in ruhe über die straße gehen
können ohne dass sie angegriffen werden
aber dafür müssen wir eben auch benennen
wer die täter sind damit wir uns auch
diese täter vornehmen und nicht so
pauschal so nach dem motto wir haben ein
rückschritt denn die wir haben dich
rückschritte wir haben bestimmte
bevölkerungsgruppen die da ein problem
mit haben und mit denen müssen wir uns
befassen ja und gleichzeitig haben wir
es ja um boden aus der 8d das ist
plötzlich wieder in ordnung
natürlich und das können sie jetzt auch
als worte bauten aber trotzdem
unterschiedlich
ich wollte so ergänzen ich glaube man
das ist richtig was sie sagen mit den
muslimen das ist so statistisch gesehen
aber es ist natürlich auch wichtig dass
die afg eine reaktionäre partei ist und
deshalb der auffassung ist dass man
keine homosexuellen paare braucht also
das muss man auch ganz klar so sehen und
ich meine die afg bekämpfen wir auch aus
anderen gründen politisch aber man muss
sie auch mit ihrem weltbild bekämpfen
das ist so und es wird immer wieder
parteien geben die sagen wir müssen hier
ein rollback machen wir haben das
gesellschaftliche ribbeck sehen wir ja
in einer ganz anderen art und weise in
den usa da waren sie ja und diese
teilung der gesellschaft da kommen wir
gleich noch drauf die wir haben sowohl
also verschärft in den usa aber
inzwischen eben auch in deutschland die
bezieht ja solche themen mit ein wir
haben in den usa es wieder eine debatte
der schwangerschaftsabbruch bei frauen
verboten werden soll hätten wir doch
auch nicht geglaubt dass das geht und
wir haben diese ganzen evangelen
evangelikalen die ganz klar sagen dass
homosexuelle beziehungen nicht gehen und
da muss man natürlich aufpassen und
deswegen das ist richtig was sie sagen
afd ist richtig andere tendenzen in der
gesellschaft ist richtig dass wir durch
corona eine größere menge von menschen
haben
nicht wir sondern quer denken ist auch
richtig und da fällt so war es dann auch
manchmal mit rein also ich glaube es ist
ein konglomerat und das gilt es zu
benennen und es gilt was dagegen zu tun
gesellschaftlich
für mich entschieden nicht mit dem
finger auf eine gruppe zu zeigen sondern
hat für mich entschieden ich engagiere
mich da lieber und gehe auf
religionsgruppen zu senates von der
moschee ich gehe auf bertold höcker von
der evangelischen kirche zu ich gehe auf
den cash at vereinen der jüdischen
vereinigung für homosexuelle zu ich gehe
auf diese leute zu verbinden sie
miteinander oder sie verbinden sich
schon selbst miteinander es gibt jeden
jedes jahr vor dem csd auch ein einen
gottesdienst für alle religiösen gruppen
und da muss dann aufklärung stattfinden
natürlich ist da überall viel zu tun
aber das ist doch in der katholischen
kirche nicht anders also ich meine aber
sie zeigt mit dem finger auf einen
gruppen-dritten zu kurz gebieten wir
wünschen ihnen auch weiterhin sehr viel
erfolg bei ihrem engagement und jetzt
machen wir am eine ganz kurze werbepause
und danach sprechen über preis explosion
und darüber wie man die spaltung der
gesellschaft vielleicht verein man kann
[Musik]
also da kann ich einen lauten und nicht
ernst nehmen als sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei 14 85 köpfen fünf meinungen
jeder von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht
was ihn bewegt tage als freud oder
schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht
herr jörges retten das auge ist aber
niemand von den politischen parteien
traut sich zu sagen ja das wollen wir
einfach nur freiheit diese grün-roten
der damen führen hochtrabende debatten
über die rettung des weltklimas und um
die füße russland die ratten das thema
ist viel zu wichtig um es nur derart zu
überlassen lasst den leuten noch mal den
spaß wir sehen da etwas was eigentlich
fatale ist in der politik bei den
journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu finden
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig gut
doch das sind übliche anorak träger aus
ich habe meinen beifall um eine sache
immer bekommt er kümmert sich darum
niemand das
ist der ganz kleine auch darüber
sprechen das ist einfach nicht fair für
mich richtig wohl ist die aufgabe von
journalismus einfach
die verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und machen direkt weiter
verlieren keine zeit mit dem thema von
béla anda
ja ich habe mich heute aufgeregt
überhoben heißt ich kann ihm ja bahnhof
und habe wollte ein ja wir wollen ja
alle lange leben ein wasser und ein
ingwer shirt kaufen sagt knapp sieben
euro ich habe so ist der salat auch
dabei er kommt extra dick sein geld
verdient sie wenigstens mehr dann dachte
der mann der der kasse mich an sagte so
ist das nicht unbemerkt ist ja alles
jeden tag alles wird zu zeit teurer
nicht mehr öl und gas sind alle
lebensmittel dinge des täglichen lebens
wenn überhaupt nicht was da ist die
begründung für diese stark steigenden
preise kennen wir auch das ist der
kleine krieg der krieg in der ukraine
dass die lieferketten die wieder
auseinander brechen dann ist es die
neuwagen in shanghai und was nicht die
begründung ist klar aber die wahrheit
ist ja das sind gründe die na ja die
auch zum teil vorgeschoben sind denn
warum ist alles bei uns in deutschland
so viel teurer als im europäischen
ausland
war ist viele machen sich nebenbei die
taschen voll viele nutzen sie die lage
um ihre preise nach oben zu schrauben
und die gewinne einzustreichen und damit
wir nicht alle dauer braucht sein muss
finanzminister davon bin ich überzeugt
jetzt eine wirklich bahnbrechenden
maßnahmen umsetzen geld muss die
mehrwertsteuer senken auf zehn prozent
und den reduzierten beitrag auf 5 und
das dauerhaft bürokratische monster wie
sie jetzt gerade beschlossen sind der
eine kriegt 300 euro mehr muss davon
aber die hälfte oder ein drittel dann
wieder ansteuern abzahlen oder es gibt
einen zuschuss aber nur wenn man einen
monat lang wohngeld bezogen hat die
helfen wirklich gar keinem weiter in
dieser situation und lindner muss mehr
sein als ein minister der als nächstes
großes ziel wieder nur die schwarze null
erreichen will der muss seine
finanzpolitik dazu nutzen
wirtschaftspolitik zu entfesseln neue
unternehmen möglich zu machen starts
möglich zu machen und den menschen
dauerhaft das zurückgeben was ihnen aus
der tasche gezogen also mehr freiheit
schaffen mehr freiheit wagen durch mehr
wirtschaftspolitische freiheit denn so
kann er den da sich und die fdp als
tolle marktliberale ergänzung zu der
staats dirigistischen haltung von robert
habeck dem wirtschaftsminister wirken
und darauf ein werk und so kann er auch
wieder wahlen gewinnen und davon haben
dann alle was die bürgerinnen und bürger
also
solltest fdp berater werden
es klingt recht haben ein konzept und es
ist ja in der tat auch so ein bisschen
konzept das ist auch schon mal bei der
cdu gab da gab es ja schon mal den
professor aus heidelberg wien gerhard
schröder immer genannt hat ja ein
bisschen dem schiffsteil wo der damals
gesagt hat 25 prozent steuern für alle
dann ist das auch ganz einfach und alle
zahlen gleich und so ein bisschen kommt
mir das jetzt mit dieser herr
abgesenkten mehrwertsteuer
ehrlicherweise auch vor es führt ja doch
nämlich dazu dass du eine ungleich dass
man eine ungleichheit hat bei dem die
leute betroffen sind also du zahlst du
dann auch nur zehn prozent auf die rolex
uhr wenn du dir eine kaufst aber man
zahlt eben zehn prozent auf die
produkte des täglichen bedarfs im sinne
von kleidung auf lebensmittel fällt ja
sowieso der geringere satz an aber weil
es was ich wenn man sich eine blaue hose
und ein paar schuhe kauft dann zahlt man
eben auch nur zehn prozent und das sind
auch die leute die weniger geld haben in
einer anderen weise betroffen als sie
die sowieso viel geld haben und deswegen
bin ich immer dagegen dass man das so
über einen kamm schert muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen sondern ich bin bei dir
ist es bürokratisch fürchterlich was da
passiert gerade
man könnte das wahrscheinlich auch ein
bisschen intelligenter machen aber es
ist auf alle fälle im ergebnis gerechter
weil es eine stärkere umverteilung
zwischen unten und oben oder oben und
unten ist ich sagte wegen wäre ich nicht
dafür dass wir machen ich sage ja auch
dass das ein erster großartiger impuls
ist weil wir haben gesehen bei der
letzten temporären kurzfristig
mehrwertsteuersenkung gab es ja auch für
die gesagt haben das wird alles
aufgefressen
es gibt sogar berechnungen von leuten
gesagt haben 60 prozent ist nur
umgesetzt worden aber es gibt jetzt
keine neue studien von der universität
von notre dame aus usa hoch angesehen
wie gesagt haben 35 millionen wurden
zusätzlich in den wirtschaftskreislauf
gesteckt weil die menschen nämlich
anschaffung vorgezogen die falschen
maschine das auto das auch er dann
werden sie eben nicht vorher werden sie
eben nicht zusätzlich in den
wirtschaftskreislauf gesteckt sondern
sie werden eben doch es gibt dahinter
werden daraufhin biss kaufimpulse also
wenn die närrische neuer frank wird ist
es tatsächlich so dass es kaufimpulse
gibt ich wäre allerdings trotzdem auch
bei einem eher differenzierten modell
ich kämpfe zum beispiel im
familienpolitischen raum schon lange
darum dass zum beispiel gerade
kinderartikel ja der babynahrung und so
weiter auch in der mehrwertsteuer wir
leben ja in einem land wo sie auf
hundefutter nur 7 prozent mehrwertsteuer
bezahlen aber an babynahrung 19 prozent
und das sind so dinge wo ich sage also
im täglichen bedarf die lebensmittel das
wo gerade auch familien die die sich
nicht mehr weiter einschränken können
weil wir haben sehr viele ganz normale
durchschnittsfamilien die wissen nicht
mehr wo sie sparen können die werden von
den energiepreisen und von den ganz
normalen lebensmittelpreisen und so
weiter aufgefressen also all das was man
braucht um kinder groß zu ziehen und was
man zum täglichen bedarf wenn wir dort
einen mehrwertsteuersatz komplett machen
bin ich absolut drei ergo ist natürlich
dass das dass das kernproblem sie sagen
die gruppe der der eltern wird
benachteiligt für die müssen wir mehr
tun brigitte zypries sagt die rolex
träger sollen nicht ist kann hier
übrigens
sollen hier übrigens sollen nicht
gestützt werden sondern es sollen die
sozial benachteiligten sind jeder
fordert eine eine kleine klientel gruppe
und keiner denkt ans kranz deswegen bin
ich dafür einen radikalen schritt zu
machen und das impuls zu nehmen unser
steuersystem wirklich zu vereinfachen
und zu sagen wie kriegen wir lieben
besten impulse für die wirtschaft gegen
diesen staatsdirigismus der parallel
läuft wird christian lindner nur die
möglichkeit hat sein geld jeden monat
rüber zu schieben zu wollen
beck der das gut aber trotzdem verteilt
starts dirigistisch wir brauchen mehr
freiheit das ist das doch die gedanken
aber so die den sinn haben sie ja beide
fast denselben dass sie etwas verbessern
wollen und deswegen würde ich direkt zu
ihrem thema überleiter frau zypries weiß
engel der sehr gut zusammen passt
ja es passt insofern
als es um das thema geht wir haben in
diesem land wir hatten es eben auch
schon mal bei ihrem thema wir haben in
diesem land eine spaltung zwischen arm
und die diskutieren wir schon seit
vielen jahren und man kann aber
feststellen dass sie stärker geworden
ist in den letzten jahren und durch die
pandemie es auch noch mal stärker
geworden ist also es gab viele leute die
in beschäftigungsverhältnissen waren wo
sie dann auf kurzarbeitergeld gegangen
sind bis zu zwei jahren und eben sehr
viel weniger einkommen hatten die
ausgaben aber nicht signifikant
runtergegangen sind also die differenz
von einkommen und vermögen steigt und
ich bin der erfassung oder nicht nur ich
das gefährdet unsere demokratie auf der
strecke weil wir eben auch feststellen
können das ist der aktuelle bezugspunkt
die wahlen in nordrhein-westfalen
letztes wochenende wir haben nur eine
wahlbeteiligung von 55 prozent gehabt
und davon haben einkommensschwache nur
mit 38 prozent
gewählt und in orten wie köln chorweiler
beispielsweise waren sogar nur 21,9
prozent die wählen gegangen sind will
heißen die gut ausgebildete und
gebildete mittelschicht geht wählen und
vertritt ihre interessen und diejenigen
die sich abgehängt fühlen die gehen auch
erst gar nicht mehr wählen und das wird
immer schlimmer und die wahlbeteiligung
sinkt kontinuierlich und mein
schlüsselerlebnis sage ich ganz ehrlich
war 2010 in hamburg als der schwarz
grüne senat unter ole von beust damals
ein konzept auf den tisch gelegt hat
dass die schülerinnen und schüler bis
zur sechsten klasse gemeinsam in die
schule gehen sollen weil man weiß dass
leute aus also dass kinder aus familien
wo man sich nicht so sehr um sie kümmert
wie in anderen familien wenn besser
gefördert werden
und dann haben eltern aus eben besagter
mittelschicht angefangene
volksinitiative dagegen zu machen es gab
eine volksabstimmung und die eltern der
kinder die eigentlich hätten dafür
stimmen müssen dass das so wird wie der
senat will händler wir haben sich nicht
beteiligt an der abstimmung und dann
haben die anderen gewonnen also nach der
vierten klasse geht man in hamburg
weiter aus gymnasium und die kinder
werden eben nicht in dem maße gefördert
wie sie gefördert werden könnten und so
kann man das jetzt eben auch auf die
ganz auf das system demokratie runter
dekliniert also wir müssen da einfach
was machen wenn wir unser system
erhalten wollen was ja auch an vielen
anderen stellen bedroht ist du hast eben
china genannt sind ukraine genannt
cyberwar und in dieses mehr also die
ganzen sozialen medien was alles damit
rein spielt ist alles nur ein
riesenthema aber was führt dann am ende
so hat das ist doch nicht der cyberwar
weil den menschen warum sie nicht zur
wahl gehen das ist
weil am ende dann irgendwie auch ihre
parteikollegin mit dem sohn mit dem
helikopter nach so fliegt die beugen
leute halte einfach keinen bock mehr
drauf und sagen sich die da oben das ist
ja mal stärker geworden das erlebe ich
doch auch selbst bei mir in der heimat
in thüringen die leute haben einfach
dann keine lust mehr sich damit zu
beschäftigen weil sie sich halt
verarscht vorkommen und nicht meinen die
letzte wahl sollte ja schon irgendwie so
ein neuer neustart werden ich glaube die
leute waren noch echt ready dafür und
der einzige der krad punkte deshalb
robert habeck war das ordentlich erklärt
und man seine politik muss man nun mal
erklären ja das hat frau merkel immer zu
wenig gemacht herr habe macht zeit gut
wie harbeck ist nach katar geflogen
werden die rechte werden wir gerade die
große dem beitrag aber er hat halt mehr
sehen benötigen video erklärt und
erklärt warum
jetzt
darum herum warum diese spaltung da ist
oder warum die menschen eben sich dann
einfach also warum auch diese soziale
spaltung dann halt daneben das haben sie
ja auch gesagt warum die leute nicht
mehr zur wahl gehen aber die die jetzt
wenn wir jetzt zum beispiel gerade köln
oder auch köln chorweiler nimmt mich
wundert ehrlich gesagt nicht dass in
solchen stadtteilen und niemand zur wahl
geht weil dort ein klientel wohnt das
quasi fast fast zu 100% irgendwie von
staatlicher alimentierung lebt denen es
völlig egal wer regiert weil es für ihr
persönliches leben über auch finanziell
überhaupt gar kein bisschen
sagen aber das interesse sozusagen in
irgendeiner form zu sagen ich will eine
andere politische ordnung ich will diese
würde jene forderung das macht dort für
viele menschen überhaupt keinen
unterschied wer regiert so und da ist
das interesse nicht da ich glaube
allerdings dass gerade endlich sagen es
ist ja nicht nur sozusagen in den
bildungsfernen schichten wird nicht
gewählt sondern zunehmend auch im
bürgerlichen lager zunehmend eigentlich
auch leute wo man sagt die waren früher
wählen das macht mir viel mehr sorgen
weil diese leute offensichtlich
irgendwie auch kein unterschied mehr
sehen ja was mich interessieren sich da
raus weil die sequenz aus dem was
brigitte zypries sagt ist oftmals ja wir
brauchen mehr staatliche förderung wir
brauchen wir hier für diese minar für
jene minderheit oder so
wie kommen wir da raus aus dieser und
der serie aus dieser lage und und ich
und was wir tun ist auch die spd als mit
dem arbeits und sozialministerium
milliarden und milliarden jedes jahr an
transferleistungen aus dem bundesrat zu
nehmen und sie schön zu verteilen und
wundern sich warum der die zumindest
zuweisung für soziale kompetenz in
nordrhein westfalen um elf prozent
ausweisen von infratest dimap weiß nicht
ob das stimmt aber zumindest haben die
so gemeldet gefallen ist obwohl diese
ganz milliarden verteilt worden sind in
den letzten jahren muss man sich doch
die frage stellt warum ist das so und
gibt es nicht bessere wege als immer nur
transfer hier transfer tat und das als
sozialer gerechtigkeit zu verkaufen
etwas was offenbar bei den bürgerinnen
und bürgern zumindest in nordrhein
westfalen nicht angekommen ist und da
bin ich wirklich bei der
chancengerechtigkeit die wir haben uns
immer auf die fahne schreiben aber wie
sieht es denn aus mit ganztagsschulen
über die wir den ganzen tag reden wie
sieht es denn wirklich aus mit der
betreuung wir waren beim schinken beim
tollen event da war frau märz immerhin
cdu geführtes bundesland damals noch in
nordrhein westfalen in düsseldorf hat
gesagt wenn ich würde das so angucke hat
sich hier überhaupt nichts verändert in
den letzten 30 jahren das sagte sie als
nrw cdu geführt ward was die betreuung
von jugendlichen oder von kindern in der
schule angeht oder die möglichkeit von
frauen dann auch tat sich am nachmittag
arbeiten zu können mit betreuten kindern
gar nichts verbessert die ausstattung
von schulen der reden die seit corona
lehrermangel ist es denn mit dem jungen
wanderung ist mit den ausstellern
arbeiterjugend arbeiter jugendclubs
ipads in den schulen passiert da was
oder passiert da nichts zum teil stellt
der bund milliarden zur verfügung das
grundgesetz wird geändert aber trotzdem
versiegt das irgendwo in den ländern und
da muss man doch endlich mal ran und
dann kann man chancengerechtigkeit über
spracherwerb über die möglichkeit
wirklich alle zu fordern meinetwegen
auch über die sechs jahren daneben um
setzt aber warum sind denn die die leute
dann dagegen auch in hamburg bei
natürlich auch eine mittelschicht angst
hat und dass ihre kinder abgehängt
werden wenn sie noch vier jahre zwei
jahre mehr mit denen zusammen sind diese
nicht als die nicht gefördert werden und
von denen sie meinen sieht sie in den
unterricht und gerecht ist das nicht
aber so ist die realität und da hilft
wirklich nur mehr investieren man kann
es nicht mehr hören aber es wird nicht
gemacht laufen also ich vielleicht
möchte wird gerappt erzählen eine
freundin von mir ist in einem
problemviertel in köln
grundschullehrerin und er sagte mir
gerade erst sonntag erzählte mir sagt
sie was sie ich kann nicht mehr sagte
ich kann langsam einfach nicht mehr
sagte seit 2015 haben wir die halbe
klasse voll hat gesagt ich habe kinder
migrantenanteil von bestimmt 60 80
prozent an der schule sagte das ist
schon enorm jüngste generation ja ja
genau nachmachen von anstrengen das ist
schon anstrengend genug dass sie dann
haben wir die flüchtlingskinder bekommen
wir tun und machen das sie werden nicht
mehr personal bekommen so jetzt haben
wir das halbwegs irgendwie in den griff
bekommen dann kam corona soja dann haben
wir jetzt corona irgendwie bewältigt
jetzt haben wir konkurrenz an bekommen
die schulen wieder offen jetzt haben wir
die ukrainischen flüchtlingskinder da
diese schulen werden aber nicht mehr
ausgestattet sie bekommen nicht mehr
personal sie sind sie sind im endeffekt
auch die lehrer sind am ende ihrer
kräfte und dann ist es ganz egal ob
diese kinder vier jahre der sechs jahre
in dieser grundschule sind wenn wir
nicht insgesamt mehr investieren in die
schule und wenn das nicht wichtiger wird
insgesamt ja dass man sagt wie findet
das überhaupt stattfindet schule
überhaupt statt und wie können wir
kinder
aber sie sagen werden nicht abgehoben
teilweise wird von den ländern nicht
abgerufen wenigstens was diese ipad
geschichten anbelangt und am auf der
anderen seite ist es auch so dass es
schon sehr vieles besser geworden ist
also jetzt ist haben sie jetzt irgendwie
alles negative aufgezählt was man
erzählen kann aber es gibt natürlich
auch viele gibt aber auch viele
gegenbeispiele die sie benennen können
wo sie sagen können das ist eine tolle
schule da sind wir noch lehrer da die
kümmern sich und da sind engagierte
lehrer es hängt oft halt auch an den
schulleiter muss nicht sagen sich elia
sind auch alle engagiert aber ich bin da
sagen die sind am ende ihrer kräfte an
das glaube ich aber auch sofort aber es
sind ganz ganz viele nach dem ende der
pandemie am ende ihrer kräfte auch die
ganzen eltern die die kinder zu hause
betreuen mussten so ist es ja nun mal
nicht
nutzt eben die schultern der em klar der
der leute die jetzt wirklich helfen das
haben wir am berliner hauptbahnhof bei
der aufnahme von den ukrainern und auch
gesehen nur der stadt reagiert gar nicht
schnell genug andere habe ich andere
staaten können das auch allein geht
nicht wie können solche mengen von
menschen die von heute auf morgen kommen
nicht durch staatliche institutionen
auffangen können weil da müssen sie in
einer art und weise vorsorge wirtschaft
treiben und leute bereit halten ständig
auf die gefahr hin dass man irgendwie
alle paar jahre so was passiert das
macht ihr überhaupt gar keinen sinn
ist mit 16 in thüringen war hatte ich
eben oder mit 14 daten wir eben ich war
einem offenen kanal den gab es da gab es
jugendprogramme es gab es gab
jugendhelfer dies gab jugendclubs und so
weiter also das angebot ist so
zurückgefahren worden und als gruppe
dann kam und auch noch sportangebote und
sportvereine sich nicht mehr getroffen
haben das hat dann das übelste getan und
also ich kenne heute selbst
bekanntenkreis wo die enkel dann
magersucht haben und unter die
hilfsangebot begrenzt sind das zählt
jetzt wieder zu sehr auf krone ansonsten
haben die spaltung aber dieser
lehrermangel und dieses dieses diese
bildung so zu vernachlässigen ich glaube
da wurde schon recht viel falsch gemacht
ja aber vielleicht die antwort zum frage
anreiz irgendwie aus der armut weil wir
sind ja nicht in frage ist ja in frage
ist wie kommen wir da raus und was mir
immer ein bisschen fehlt wie also bei
mir stellt sich ja immer die nackenhaare
aufwendig umverteilung höre ja weil ich
immer sage irgendjemand muss das ja
verdienen was umverteilt wird und ich
arbeite ja auch den ganzen tag um meine
kinder zu ernähren und auch viele im
niedriglohnsektor stehen morgens auf und
machen ihre arbeit und mir fehlt immer
ein bisschen der anreiz ich möchte nicht
umverteilen ich finde das auch
entwürdigend langfristig
beispielsweise soja mindestlohn
verteilen sie ein gewisser weise auch um
und es ist richtig dass der mindestlohn
eingeführt wurde und ist es auch richtig
dass der mindestlohn erhöht wurde aber
gleichzeitig ist es trotzdem so dass
dass wir zu viel wir haben einen
wachsenden anteil von menschen die von
transferleistungen
leben das sind die bis in die rente
hinein nicht von ihrem eigenen
erwirtschafteten geld erleben können
verkenne dass eine umverteilung werden
sie noch mal mit mir oder biblis wir
werden da dranbleiben jetzt aber sind
wir am ende der sendung angekommen ich
bedanke mich herzlich bei meinen gästen
und brigitte zypries birgit keller und
bilder anderen wenn sie mögen schreiben
sie doch morgen abend wieder ein schöner
abend noch chips
[Musik]